>>A fraction with the
same number on the top
and bottom is a unit fraction.
>>Narrator: At Forest
Lake Elementary,
students are assessed
early and often.
>>Two nights plus three
nights plus one night.
>>Narrator: Some of
the tests are fun,
and most of them employ
the latest technology.
>>Would someone like
to share what they put?
>>I put A because I added
one plus two plus three.
>>Narrator: The goal is to
find out where each student is
and then devise an
individual learning strategy
that will help them
get to the next level.
>>Good. Get that in there.
>>I don't think there's
a school in the world
where you have a regular classroom
where everyone is exactly the same.
I think many, many years
ago, students who were
in teacher education programs learned
how to kinda teach down the middle
and do a little here
and a little there.
Well, we know that that's not
right for children, and there's no
such thing as a regular classroom.
Our school is a microcosm of
the world, so we work very hard
to make sure that we
know where children are.
We don't take time to teach
things that they already know.
We try to go where they are
and take them as far as we can.
>>And measure the different level?
>>Oh, we learned something
a little bit different.
>>At the beginning of the year,
we do a variety of assessments.
We have our MAT testing, which
is a computerized assessment,
and it gives us feedback as far
as different literary strands
and mathematical strands.
And it breaks it down for each child
to let us know what range they're in
and how we can better group them,
or how we could better teach
them within those groups.
>>I decide I want to be a police
officer the two officers came
to our school.
>>We also have Palm Pilots where
we sit one on one with the child
and we assess their
reading abilities.
And so you really get a very
good educational profile
of that student based
on all of this data.
>>They go whenever there is a
problem, and they try to help--
>>Tamika: A lot of times, I'll just
pull out my information that I have
on each student and I'll say,
"Okay, how can I group them
to better serve them for
this particular skill?"
So the groups are fluid
and it's all based
on how we can meet educational needs.
>>A person who's advanced
to detect a crime.
Detective.
>>Tamika: We have a
group at the smart board.
What they're doing now is, they're
working on their vocabulary.
There's also spelling
practice on there,
and I also include skills practice.
>>Who's on this computer?
>>Tamika: Here at the tech zone,
they're having a blackboard
discussion.
We've been studying the genre of
fantasy and I was able to look
at those that were
stronger in literary text
and have them actually convert a non
fiction text into a fantasy text,
by changing the different elements.
Those that were a little weaker,
I actually had them come in
and comment on the edits.
>>Kevin: Then that's
when you're ready
to actually start filming, okay?
>>Narrator: In his
fourth grade classroom,
a one to one computer student ratio
helps Kevin Durden individualize the
study of math, science,
language arts and social studies.
>>Martha Washington.
There she is.
>>We use a model for teaching called
IPAC, which is individualized,
personalized, authentic
and collaborative learning.
It's personalized, in that
everybody's showing their learning
in a way that is comfortable to them.
They're learning the subject
matter that we assign,
but they're expressing
it in different ways.
>>I'm creating a battle on the game
called Medieval Two and we have
to research what kind
of people they had there
and like the terrain
of the land and stuff.
>>Kevin: It's authentic in that
at the end of the projects,
they'll be sharing them
with their classmates.
And it's collaborative in that
the students that are working
on similar projects will help
each other when they learn how
to use new technology
tools or new software.
Or alternatively, for
example, for the students
that are doing the skits,
they're actually working
collaboratively right now
in order to create scripts.
>>Yes, please.
What a lovely home.
I hope you don't mind, but I
brought my daughter, Abigail.
>>Kevin: We're able to use a variety
of different software in order
for students to present
their learning.
For example, this young gentleman
here used software called Comic Life.
And so he's got his
picture of Australia there
and he's got a bearded
dragon emerging from an egg,
so that he can talk about that
part of the reptile life cycle.
And he says that the bearded
dragon is an herbivore,
and that is something that I
would not have gotten out of him
if I'd asked him to do
three paragraph essay.
He'd have sat there, and he'd
have spun around in the chair
and he'd have tapped his pencil and
he'd have balled up several pieces
of paper before I got
anything out of him.
But as it is, with Comic Life, he's
dragging and dropping the photos
in there and then he's only gonna
write his little thought bubbles.
And so the graphic scaffold his
ability to use the language.
>>Sandra: Gavin and Andy,
I'm gonna let you start
at the little tech zone
right over here, okay?
>>Narrator: During the research phase
of a project, students are placed
at various stations
in the media center
to best accommodate their
individual learning styles.
>>Don't forget to look in the
reference books, along with the--
>>We have three stations set up,
because this will hit a variety
of learning styles for all
the students that we teach.
>>Do you wanna use the pointer and
make it go up a little bit more?
>>I'm constantly observing
the students.
And of course, we do occasionally
give paper and pencil test as well,
but so much of our assessment
is done through observation
or through checklist, anecdotal
records, journaling in the computer,
keeping records on each student.
And we know which learning
style that each student has
and we know how they
would learn best.
>>Isn't it a lot of
work on your part?
>>Oh, of course, it's a lot of work,
but that's what we're here for.
We want to help each and every
student that we teach and we feel
like we're just making a huge
difference in each child's life.
>>There shouldn't be a comma right
there, but there should be a comma.
>>Riley, air high five.
Awesome. Let's keep going, friends.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org